[Music]
recess school's out is a strange
contradiction of a film first of all the
title makes no sense if school's out how
can there be recess will be ruined
second I kind of figured the Saturday
morning TV show was based on was
centered around well recess kids getting
together goofing around giving it all
sorts of silly antics upsetting adults
so on and so forth and if that's what
the show is like then that's definitely
not reflected that much in the movie the
movie opens with a military base being
broken into and all these guys break in
and they Shack the guards and this guy
with a cane comes in and he's using this
satellite to control the moon and what
the hell kind of movie did I get into on
the one hand I say to myself this kind
of insanity might actually be kind of
fun but it never quite goes far enough
for it to be really really funny there's
one or two funny moments have one or two
funny lines but a lot of it sadly just
comes across as a generic kids adventure
so after that James Bond intro we get a
poorly rendered CGI opening of the
school thank God there's only one more
of these in the movie we're all our main
characters as well as all the other kids
in the school are being led out for
summer vacation our main lead TJ is once
again giving under the skin of his
principal mr. prickly played by Dabney
Coleman TJ is excited because he gets to
hang out all summer with his friends but
it looks like all his friends are going
to different various camps space camp
performing arts camp wrestling camp and
so forth when he thinks he has to spend
the summer all by himself he realizes
that something strange is going on at
the school a weird green light is coming
from the windows and when he Pete's
inside it looks like a laser beam is
being created he goes to the cops will
of course don't believe him so he has no
choice but to get all his friends out of
their various camps to help him out
it looks like the organization making
the beam is led by a villain played by
James Woods for he has a plan to get
revenge on principal prickly as well as
destroy recess forever so that test
scores can go up and people will hail
him as the greatest mind ever maybe even
make him president okay so on the
surface that kinda sounds like a funny
plot like it's so absurd and so
something a kid would come up with that
it could be entertaining and like I said
before parts are every once in a while
there's a funny line or
funny idea and the villains details in
how he's gonna get rid of recess is so
funny I won't even spoil it for you it's
just beautifully ridiculous but sadly
the script needed a lot more humor a lot
of the jokes are just kind of very basic
jokes and half the time they're not even
making them like they're running down
the hallway and they come across ninjas
and that's just kind of it the ninjas
don't do anything funny they don't say
anything funny they're not a special
kind of ninja they're just
run-of-the-mill ninjas and a lot of the
action scenes jokes and characters are
kind of along the same lines they're
just kind of generic I really want to
like these kids it seems like they have
very defined personalities but they just
don't do anything that interesting in
this film I want to see funny things at
wrestling camp I want to see funny
things at Space Camp I want to see this
goofy villain do really crazy goofy
things on top of the weird plan he has
but I don't know if they ran out of time
to write it or throwing more jokes but a
lot of it comes off as just kind of
boring there is kind of a nice lesson
connecting TJ and the principal showing
that not all adults are against kids
they were once kids too in fact seeing
how many adults come together to fight
for recess it's actually kind of a cool
thing I think seems like this and even a
really nice speech that the principal
makes about the importance of recess
will probably resonate the most with
kids and adults but aside from that they
just kind of do the kids by adventure
thing that every other kids by adventure
does nothing really that new is added or
that many funny elements thrown in and
even when there is a legitimate amoment
it's very brief and doesn't carry the
film seeing how I never watched the show
I have no idea this is an accurate
portrayal of what it was like or fans of
the show would like this I guess his
kids would find it ok and parents would
get through it alright but I don't know
how good the rewatch ability is aside
from just having something on in the
background
I guess it's silly to be harsh on it
because there's nothing really awful in
it there's no bad lessons there's no
jokes that make you want to go nuts or
yell at the screen but the same time
this seems like kind of a fun idea just
showing what recess is like in this
group of friends and how they work off
each other or if you're gonna go for
this big crazy plot about this evil
mastermind go all out you have James
Woods as your villain the funny is part
of Hercules he's a funny voice
to make him funny as is it's just kind
of a run-of-the-mill adventure if you
have a nostalgic connection and you
don't need that much extra to get into
these characters and their stories
they're enough but this is a play time
where I'm not exactly dreading the Bell
[Music]